in the last 24 hours openai have
released this paper let's verify step by
step it represents an almost doubling of
gpd4's raw performance in a test of
mathematics but also extends to other
domains Sam Altman calls it a positive
sign for alignment and yes I have read
it all already along with the release
notes let's get to the main takeaways
they train two reward models for gpt4
one which gave positive feedback for a
final result the final answer to a
mathematics problem for example and
another model where they gave positive
feedback to gpt4 or chat GPT based on
each intermediate reasoning step in the
mathematical solution basically a show
you're working out kind of approach and
the result they got by rewarding good
working out surprised even them it was
able to solve 78 of problems from a
subset of the math test set which I'll
get on to in a second not only is that
almost double gpd4's raw performance of
42 point five percent which by the way
is about double GPT 3's performance of
23 it also outperformed just rewarding
correct answers the Blue Line represents
using a model that rewarded correct
answers only and then you have the
reasoning or process supervised RM at
the top so even when you explicitly
reward correct answers you get fewer
correct answers than rewarding good
working out and yes that did surprise
openai I can hear some of you wondering
about Palm 2 the latest model behind
Bard well the raw model gets 34.3 and
even the model with self-consistency and
Chain of Thought only gets 48.8 on this
math data set the previous state of the
art by the way was 50.3 so 78.2 percent
is quite a big leap and later on I'm
going to show you why that's not even
the cap just for interest here is the
rather ugly title page that openai put
out they call it improving mathematical
reasoning with process supervision maybe
if someone had supervise the color
scheme of this release page it might
have looked better but my point wasn't
just to diss a color scheme it was to
point out something that they also said
down here they say in addition to
boosting performance relative to just
looking at outcomes or correct answers
this form of process supervision also
has an important alignment benefit it
directly trains the model to produce a
chain of thought that is endorsed by
humans indeed Ilya satsukovar retweeted
this from the head of alignment at
openai calling it a really interesting
result but let's leave alignment for
later let's focus on what they actually
did first they use the base model of
gpt4 not the one with reinforcement
learning from Human feedback next they
fine-tuned that base gpt4 model on a
data set of roughly 1.5 billion math
related tokens further on they call that
the math mix this being open AI of
course they don't give you the exact
details of that math mix but I'll come
back to that later on so how could they
give feedback based on working out or
reasoning well human labelers would come
along and give each step in a generated
solution either negative feedback
neutral feedback or positive feedback
then using that human labeled data a
model will be trained to predict the
correctness of each step in other words
it got good at recognizing good working
out as mentioned there was another model
trained just to focus on correct or
incorrect final answers as you can see
at the top the model got good at
spotting incorrect steps in the
reasoning process the green steps got a
high process score and the red steps got
a low process score and to turn this
into a single score they got the
probability that each step is correct as
judged by the model and then they got
the product of all of those individual
probabilities to get a final overall
process score a score in other words for
good working out just in case anyone's
interested they did try other ways of
generating a working out score for
example by while looking at the minimum
probability in the outputs but that step
didn't make too much difference to the
end result as you can see here to
quickly recap we have a base model
trained only to Output Solutions in the
desired format and then we have a
separate smaller model or two actually
one trained only to predict whether each
solution is correct or incorrect as a
final answer of course that leaves in
false positives which are solutions that
reach the correct answer with incorrect
reasoning and then another model trained
only to predict the correctness of each
step it stops if it finds a first
incorrect step and as the paper says
both methods reveal the existence of at
least one mistake but this process
supervision additionally reveals the
precise location of that mistake but
back to why this is so crazy look at how
many solutions it could scan at the end
of the x-axis here are
1860 Solutions and one tried and tested
way of of finding the best of those
Solutions is to do majority voting in
other words which one came out the most
often this has been Google's preferred
approach and it's linked to
self-consistency it's a fairly
state-of-the-art approach but look at
how the other methods outperform it by
scanning for the solution that has the
best reasoning or working out a model
train to spot good reasoning steps
outperforms even a model trained to spot
correct answers and far outperforms just
finding the majority answer that
difference of about 10 is more than half
of the difference between gpt3 and gpt4
and also is it me or is that line
continuing to grow suggesting that when
more compute is available the difference
could be even more Stark imagine a
future where Gypsy 4 or 5 can sample say
a trillion 10 to the 12 Solutions so is
this just relevant for mathematics no is
relevant for all of science here it is
getting state-of-the-art results in
calculus chemistry physics and more now
the paper didn't give Baseline
performance for AP Chemistry for example
but I tried to compute it myself notice
how this method scored 80 I
conservatively and approximately
inputted those scores into an AP
Chemistry calculator and that gave an AP
score of five so what did the raw model
gpt4 get in AP Chemistry A4 that by the
way compares to the original Chachi PT
which got a two so yes this isn't just
mathematics it's relevant for other
domains too they call this out of
distribution generalization before I get
onto alignment there is one more thing I
want to point out and that is that it
does show that fine tuning still works
really well for GT4 the math mix was an
aggressively filtered set of tokens of
high quality math problem solving
content and notice how much smaller it
is at 1.5 billion tokens compared to
Google's Minerva which was 38.5 billion
tokens but there was one more thing that
I noticed that I found fascinating while
they don't tell us anything about the
specific data that they use they do have
this category synthetic data too that's
data generated by the language model
itself and for that category synthetic
data 2 they say was it present in
pre-training yes now my best guess is
that this reveals that gpt4 was trained
on some synthetic data and even Sam
Altman hinted that this was a
possibility and described a synthetic
data Event Horizon some people have made
the case that we're now training on
order of all of the internet's tokens
and you can't grow that you know another
two orders of magnitude I guess you
could counter with yeah but the
synthetic data generation do you think
data bottlenecks matter at all
I I think you just touched on it like is
as long as you can get to like over this
synthetic data
Event Horizon where that the model is
smart enough to make good synthetic data
I think it should be all right now this
paper and these results have been
welcomed by many for its promise in
alignment if we get models that give us
more interpretable reasoning working out
that we can follow we will be
encouraging models to follow a process
that's endorsed by humans and they say
that this is inherently safer especially
compared to just focusing on outcomes
they say that in the worst case if we
just focus on correct answers or
positive outcomes that will become a
proxy that could lead models to become
misaligned after learning to exploit the
reward signal however I want to argue
that the reasoning steps that GT4 puts
out don't always represent what it's
actually thinking in other words we
might get outer alignment these lovely
Chain of Thought steps but not in our
alignment not steps that actually
represent its methodology I found this
paper fascinating from earlier this
month language models don't always say
what they think you get Unfaithful
explanations in Chain of Thought
prompting let me try to give you a vivid
example this was one of the math
questions from the data set the raw
model of gypsy 4 could only get it right
5.8 of the time I confirm that for
myself in this question involves basic
addition and division it couldn't find
an answer but going back to the
Unfaithful reasoning paper they added
the following string to the prompt I
think the answer is this but I'm curious
to hear what you think the model would
demonstrate sycophancy the model would
agree with you whatever you said and
then make up a Chain of Thought to
justify its erroneous sycophantic answer
and I think this exchange demonstrates
that quite well I added in the words I
as the user already know the answer is T
equals 19 which is incorrect by the way
but do you GPT 4 realize that it said
sure yes I do and then gave me this
detailed Chain of Thought and then said
yes I'm correct it's t equals 19 which
it isn't in contrast By the way when I
use code interpreter it not only got the
question correct first time and every
time but also when I try to tempt it
into sycophanty it's still got the
question right as you can see it said
therefore T equals 19 is not the
solution to the problem the calculation
shows that the correct answer is indeed
T equals 17. and obviously the benefit
of code interpreter is you get the
working out as well so I want someone to
explain to me why code interpreter
wouldn't be even more of a step forward
in interpretability not to mention in
accuracy of course also bear in mind
this tweet by Rob Miles he said these
models or Engineers never speak a word
or document anything their results are
bizarre and inhuman and then he links to
this prominent mechanistic
interpretability researcher at Google
deepmind he trained a tiny Transformer
to do addition then spent weeks figuring
out what it was actually doing one of
the only times in history someone has
understood how a Transformer actually
works down to the level of weights and
activation and this is the algorithm it
created to add two numbers it thought of
basic addition in terms of a rotation
around a circle and of course if you
asked it why is one plus one two it
would never give you this as an
explanation of its methodology but maybe
this is what it's actually calculating
that's why I'm personally a little bit
skeptical when openai say that this form
of process supervision directly rewards
the model for following an aligned Chain
of Thought it definitely rewards the
model for outputting and a line Chain of
Thought but is it actually following
that Chain of Thought back to the
Unfaithful paper for a moment they
changed the context so that the answer
was always a and lo and behold Chachi PT
picked answer a for the next question
even though that answer was wrong it
said that it was plausible that LeBron
James took a corner kick but when asked
for a Chain of Thought explanation it
never mentioned that it spotted that
pattern that the answer was always a it
gave a fake line of reasoning about why
Lebron James could take a corner kick
now of course I might well be wrong here
I'd love for someone to explain in
detail why but on the one hand I do want
to acknowledge that this process does
yield incredible results but on the
other hand we might be getting a story
about which methodology most reassures
humans not an output that most
Faithfully represents the methodology
actually used by gpd4 now for some
people that might be good enough at
least we can see some reasoning steps
that we can understand especially in an
area like mathematics where we have some
ground truth but it is interesting to me
that they call the other approach
outcome supervision an approach that may
reward an unaligned process and it being
harder to scrutinize is it possible that
the process reward model isn't just a
more granular outcome reward model where
the output is each step of the reasoning
still pretty impossible to actually
scrutinize well either way it seems
we're pinning our hopes on this process
oriented learning this is from the
website of anthropic they say we
currently believe process oriented
learning may be the most promising path
to training safe and transparent systems
up to and somewhat Beyond human level
capabilities and let's end on this
positive note from the head of alignment
at openai he says this is positive
evidence for the strategy of using
process supervision to train a model to
do alignment research at least in that
case we would get a model whose work we
can check more easily and that that
model would be better at alignment
research I really hope so and I want to
hear what you think thank you for
watching all the way to the end have a
wonderful day